[Music]
hi everybody welcome to another week my
choice so for this week I wanted to do a
little troll back to sink fold cup 2019
one of my favorite games between so
Vesely and Fabriano karana
it was a really interesting game and I
thought it would be a good choice to
show that and just review something like
that
alright let's dive in so this game they
started with c4 English opening and E 5
well this is a very interesting choice
because I also play e5 and it was really
interesting for me to see something like
that and alright G 3 9 f 6 yeah
so there are other lines that in
probably lower levels could be played
something like the reverse Sicilian
whoops
with knight c6 and then you could try to
do some ideas with like a v g6 and fee
on keto the bishop stuff like that I
think those are good ideas to play in
like this game or between lower rated
players or when you're facing a weaker
opponent and you just want to outplay
them out of the opening so but so and
Fabi are pretty close in level so it
wouldn't have probably been the best
idea
so after Knight of 6 Bishop g2 seems
like the logical move I think my c3 is
also pretty good move but anyways so the
theoretically d5 is the main line that I
know
and after take take if Knight c3 there
is this Knight b6 and the idea is that
you want to play Knight out
Bishop here castle and try to do
something like Bishop e6
and you're controlling so many squares
and your pieces are like all together
and I like that just because
strategically it's a very nice position
but Fabiano had a pretty deep prep from
what I remember
and so this he played c6 after Bishop g2
c6 all right I think it's good idea to
take a little bit of time or pause the
video and think about where should
White's pieces be because white could
try to do something like III and bring
the knight from e2 could do d3 bring up
Bishop and then bring out the Knights
from D to C 3 just so you get a good
idea of where the pieces are supposed to
be alright so in the game so vastly
played 9 f3 Knight f3 first glance what
is the first time you think about for me
the first move that I think about is
something like e 4 because with E 4
you're attacking the knight now Knight
has to move and Knight doesn't really
have a very stable place to go that's
why maybe d3 would have been slightly
more steady but I don't really know what
was so less less preparation so I can't
speak for him after a night of tree
efore is what happened in the game as
well and now Knight comes to d4 now
immediately after Knight d4 the moves
that you could think of are you either
could think about bringing the Queen up
you could think about bringing the
Bishop out and the idea is that you want
to attack this week pawn and you want to
have this diagonal all
packed up and ready for attack Bishop c5
could be faced with night b3 and then
you wouldn't really know what to do with
the bishop if you come back there Louis
c5 and also your queen where do you want
to place the Queen
so Queen b6 was played in the game which
I do think was a very smart choice here
white white knight b3 now do you think
III should be a candidate move to think
about I think that the answer is yes
because the knight here is pretty strong
and even if Bishop c5 now the knight
could just go back to e 2 or B 3 and
keep attacking this Bishop also III
would kind of blind this diagonal for
white for black however it does open up
some weaknesses here but black is
nowhere near ready to try and maneuver
around them so white white knight b3 the
idea is pretty much to control this is
square so Bishop c5 won't be happening
right now so take another few seconds
and think how can you come up with a
plan that you would want to play this
Bishop c5
how can you distract or make this knight
move away kind of gave it up though
anyways so the idea is that you would
follow up with a 5 and after a 5 you
your idea is simple you want to push a 4
and you want to trap the night so the
next move that white does should be
something about opening up squares for
the night
and the game d3 was played which I do
think was pretty much the only logical
move because something like a for its
thesis like such a nice outpost
I feel like night a6 night before would
have been played pretty immediately so
d3 now we get to play our a four night
goes to D 2 and after night goes to d2
you see a new idea with III I'm not
entirely sure if III works immediately
because even if simply take take the
night could start jumping around and the
bishop would be coming at it would be so
much nicer if you could after e3 fe3
take with bishop right so play Bishop c5
your idea is to control this square now
you want to play III oops sorry
also d5 was a move that Fabiana had
played previously in another game so
probably so Leslie was prepared for this
line mmm just maybe not his first choice
that would be happening in that game
anyways after night each you Bishop c5
what do you think should happen well I
think some of the candidate moves to
make is cast oh you completely ignore
the e3 idea or you put something like
III and you face it immediately you
block this idea you block this diagonal
you block the e3 idea from black sides
those are the two moves that you should
be calculating let's look at e3 first
they move that eat after e3 white should
be calculating is take now Castille
probably and this is a
game that was actually played 2018
between these gentlemen's yeah
also and after III instead of for
example short castle Knights III was
also played by mayor versus Buckland in
Bill 2016 and they followed it up with
Queen a 6p3 a tree and the dad came also
ended in a draw so in this game Castle
was played which at the time was a
novelty and after Castle now black gets
to play III so now do you think this
castle was like a bluff to invite her
III or was it more like calculated and
so basically what what would you do as
black would you go for e3 or not well in
the game they did go for e3 and after e3
f takes III Bishop takes III King is one
now what's the what are the squares that
you would want to dominate well I think
first of all this this is such a nice
hole to try and jump into so I guess 94
should be the first move to consider for
black and that is also what they did in
the game they followed up at 94 and
white only has one move what do you
think that movies take two seconds to
figure that out
yep it should be 94 whoops
should be 94 because if something like
clean you want now you just get night of
two and well he lose a exchanged least
of all so 94 is the only move now this
knight on e4 is protecting f2 and is
also threatening something like check
which would also be attacking this guy
and this guy and you wouldn't really
want that for yourself as black so you
have two choices you can either think
about d5 and kind of call this 94th
Bluff or if 94 is really a good move
then you should cast all and try to
prepare for f5 or d5 what do you think
you should do well if you would play d5
1096 where would you place your king
because if King comes to f8 rook F 7 is
coming up f king goes to d8 Knight takes
epsilon is coming up if you go to Bishop
sorry King g7 now another move that's
coming up and it's quite unpleasant as
Bishop h3 these are the little move that
might be a little hard to think about
because your your King is happening here
why would you move it all the way from a
different side but this night is
threatening to come over here if you
take rookie takes f7 King takes d6 and
you're out of checks if you would play
Knight takes f7 Knight f2 is very strong
so you have to do something as white and
Bishop h3 seems to be pretty strong
because if something like f5 then Knight
takes f5 if something
[Music]
and yeah this seems to be the way to go
I'm pretty sure tonight of seven is also
strong enough bishop h3 might not be
your first choice and if you don't see
it that's okay but Bishop history is a
move worth considering because your
bishop would be trying to handle this
strong night at least pin it so if
Bishop h3 is something like h5
now there's nine f7 I also do think
something like Knight c8 is good enough
because now if King c8 there should be
Bishop h3 and again the same idea of
pinning even if rook takes c8 again here
and if night if to simply take and
wax queen is under attack so yeah d5 is
not a very good move sacs and pressures
bad move so after Knight e4 you got a
castle you got a safe here King and now
you want to come up with ideas with d5
and f5 and stuff like that so what do
you think white should do keep in mind
that these bishops are facing each other
and could be that should that would be
an idea but you can't take it right now
because of 93 and you would get Forks so
they moved at a point in the game was
night simply developing the night and I
think this is a very smooth move because
it also controls this d5 ideas so you
can't play d5 that easily because if d5
simply take now that's just something to
consider so we were talking about d5 or
f5 now the question is do you want to
play d5 or f5 how can you how can you
start calculating about it try to find
if something is wrong with f5 because
with f5 you are not really sacrificing
upon whereas with d5 it's take take and
then the night could take and you would
be sacrificing upon so it would make
much more sense if f5 was actually good
enough
the problem with f5 is even though it's
directly attacking the night and why
it's not going to move the night why it
could also attack your night with a move
such as h3 if you take on e fourth take
rook take back h6 three four and you see
blacks pieces are not really ready to
come out this it's gonna take so many
moves for the bishop to come out with a
knight to come out or the rook to come
out while these are getting exchanged
pretty you know next few moves and white
pieces are more ready to come out this
efore pawn is a weakness so as soon as
you see f5 h3 and you go after up until
the end of that move sixteen end of that
line you should be able to make the
decision that f5 shouldn't really be
your move so now start thinking about D
5 D 5 well what kinda has to take
because if now H tree now you can take
and if take now the bishop is open
Bishop could take the pawn or I'm pretty
sure you could even try and
just simply win upon by something like
this
you just won upon and you just you'll
just follow up you just continue your
you try to bring your night out you can
put it simple you don't need to go make
crazy tactics those might come out later
so after C takes d5 what do you think
black should do because if you take back
well I'm not gonna give it out that easy
first of all think about what your
candidate know should be to make handy
tools think about checks first using any
viable checks the only check that I see
is night of 2 but that's not really the
way you would want to go because night
except to Bishop takes f2 and you don't
really have anything the other can be
able to try and make is exchange or
takes you could think about this take
you could think about this take if it
works you could think about this take
and those are the only takes that are
well clean be tools also take but you
should be able to eliminate that pretty
fast so in order to make so these candid
moves Knight issue also doesn't work
ideally if you could give a check right
after an ith - okay that - that will
work but in this situation it doesn't so
the moves to think about our Bishop
takes the bishop or you just take your
pawn back those are the two moves that
you should start calculating on and
let's take a look at take back if take
back now your queen and your bishop are
being attacked so it's about time to
move the Queen to the other side of the
board you're also attacking mate and if
h4 I don't really see an easy way for
black to improve the position
and also this two nights on the center
are really really strong this Bishop is
under attack you can't really change it
up because just Queen Queen takes back
and offer any exchange Queens and white
is just a pawn up and better development
and even though the King might look weak
you can't really attack it right now so
as soon as you see that your attack is
kind of dead you should consider Bishop
take c1 after Bishop takes c1 rook c1 is
a blunder because of 93 so you could
think about Queen C 1 now what would you
want to do after Queen c1 do you want to
take the power back or would you want to
play something like an intermediate ish
move with 93 attacking the rook
attacking the bishop maybe you want to
take your pawn back whoops that is not a
move so 93 is the right way to go
because after rook comes to f3 you see
rook f3 is pretty much the best move
because if something like looking for or
rook f2 or anything with the rook that's
not attacking the knight you could just
take back this pawn with the pawn attack
the e4 Knight let's say let's oh my god
alright let's just say true care for you
could easily take back your pawn attack
the knight now Knight has to go some way
where do you want to go D - f - lets go
- D - now you could even think about
bringing out the other night or you
could try to think about pushing and
making a stronger outpost here so you
see you blacks position starts a nice
flow so that's why rook f3 should be the
only move now try to think a little bit
about whether or not you want to take
the bishop or you want to take the pawn
with your knight
okay let's talk about taking back the
pond with the night you see if you take
that whites position is kind of ready to
burst with something like Queen g5 and
you don't really have enough pieces to
come to help your king or to cover it up
or to try and participate in the attack
whereas whites next few moves could be
to take on d5 give Knight f6 check
bringing the other rook to f1 White has
a nice flow so Queen g5 and it's quite
unpleasant now so you as soon as you see
Queen g5 and you see that the attack is
coming your way and you can't really
close it up you can't think about 92
that's about time King takes g2 now you
see that as Queen g5 attack is still
coming up so think about a move that
would kind of block off or control the
Queen on g5
that wolf is queen d8 you're controlling
your weak squares of knight on f6 or
queen coming to g5 you can't really play
something like h6 because Knight f6 is
is it still possible is a viable threat
and also another way to think about who
does your queen is not doing anything
here your Queens job is done you need
the Queen to come back to this side of
the board so bring the Queen home now if
white were to take on your D 6 D takes
c6 pawn you could simply take back with
the knight and this kind of helps your
development even though white is up upon
this is kind of better slightly better
compared to what happened the game for
you now if Queen g5 and wants to trade
off the Queen's simply you bring in your
knight take take you have to move the
rook now the knight could try to jump a
little farther or could try to create
some weaknesses over here could try to
do some b5 before you see black black
get some possibilities but after Queen
d8 Queen g5 is the best move to play
especially because well you know that
simple rule that when you're up material
it's a good idea to trade off your heavy
pieces here is that and also white can
kind of has only a few choices because
if it was black to move again black
would take this guy so white has to
either take this or come up with a way
to protect this pawn here so Queen g5
would you want to take the Queen
honestly I wouldn't be very inclined to
do so because Knight takes d5 and black
is simply a pawn down in the endgame I
mean black would try to jump some stuff
around
see how it goes but I I wouldn't be very
comfortable playing this as black so in
the game black actually continued well
continued with f6 rejecting who in
exchange now do you think it's a good
idea do you think white can take up sex
simply
okay so you want to take on f6 we do
what do you want to take with Drew you
want to say goodnight
maybe no right now
that would be super right yes
now right now that
okay why wha what are you afraid of
let's say Knight takes rook takes
I think so I think that's actually I
don't really see the difference between
bringing the rook first or the knight to
the attack first but those are the moves
that should be coming up in the game
they followed it up with Knight comes to
e4 first and how would you try to defend
the rook with the black pieces
we are back
brookey faith should be one of your
candid moves but oops what do you think
happens after rook f8 if white were to
exchange the Queen's you would simply be
a piss-up so awesome
but what worry what would you do if you
were white
yeah good job I can't now black can't
exchange to clean because of meat so
what should black do now I guess I have
to ask what could black do
but the problem is even h6 truck takes
Oh 97 I mean
but your queen is hanging yeah yeah
Rukia faith is actually not not good it
loses because I broke f1
I guess
and if take now you want to play
something like night out
yeah
yeah but you're still 2 pound pounds
done so I mean worst case scenario white
could just exchange everything off and
just take this pawn and watch two pawns
up easy win all right okay yeah
so after 94 Rookie of it doesn't work
what trick f8 is the move that you
should calculate and see why it doesn't
work and as soon as you see that you
realize that all right my rook is pinned
make peace with the Rope going bye-bye
and try to make the best of it
how with 97 now if something like Knight
takes f6 you just take back and it's
actually a pretty happy position ever
comes to f1 I think this is what
actually happened in the game you can
just play King h8 yeah let's go back to
the game because after rook f1 so 94
Knight comes to d7 and rook F 1 here
I think the same idea applies still
coming up for the mate and now your roof
is also under attack yeah yeah no way to
save the rook a good question cool so
Knight comes to d7 drew close to f1 now
as black what are the moves that you
should be considering because let's face
it this rook is falling
I think h6 is should be at least one of
your candidate males so what's the thing
what is the problem with your position
what's the big problem with your
position besides the fact that you
didn't have time to develop
okay
also this this pawn is pinned right so
I'm pennants know that King
yeah see if King f8 new king is a little
still in the middle of the board so you
also mentioned h6 m m h6 is also kind of
same stuff Knight takes check now if you
take with the Knights there is a queen
of Queens e6 that is still attacking
your night with the rook and the pawn is
is still pending can't really move it
because of rook takes f6 so it makes
more sense to get rid of the pin right
all right
so after King gets eight nine five six
four white seems like the move to to do
right because if not minus 6 then what
is why it's really trying to push for
now if night after Knight takes f6
Knight f6 is the best move gf6 I think
something like Queen h6 kind of scares
me the problem is I don't think the
problem is the the fact that it scares
me the problem is it scares me because
how are you gonna try to bring out this
Knight this Bishop this rook whereas
when you would take with the knight now
your bishop is kind of trying to take
some breath your rook could come out you
know you try to create more chances for
yourself as black so now I take then I
take back now as white something like
rook f6 doesn't work anymore cuz just g
f6 and if you do rook f6 again you don't
really have a threat you don't really
have made your rook has panned you don't
really have any checks to take my queen
and also this seems like a reasonable
exchange right
yeah so that's why I recap six doesn't
work now Rick f 6 doesn't work mainly
because of this Queen T 5 so the way you
should think about it in the game is you
want to recap 6 but e for doesn't but
your d5 pawn is weak I gave up the move
so you have to play a four to defend
this pawn now you want to go with [ __ ]
rook takes f6 black really needs to try
and bring out some pieces in the game
they play Bishop d7 I don't really see
anything else any like other way to try
and develop so let's go with that
the other problem is something like e 5
is coming up and now your knight has
pinned oops if if it were white to move
again something like e 5 is happening
you're nice and I've 6s pins and 2
because of the defenseless d8 Queen oh
my god so now you have to play something
like you have to move your Bishop to
defend your queen with the rope so the
short e 7 is pretty much the only
logical move to do after Bishop d7 now
try to make candidate moves because as
white and you do have a good position
it's not really winning your super
advantage or anything you just have more
space and the more pressure on your
opponent so try to think of different
ways that's how it would go how what
should you do
be careful remember how earlier you said
that your back rank is weak if you if
you move the night yeah so that is that
is a weakness so the back rank is weak
it is wiped white in Moodle so try to be
as white one of your ideas could be to
play something like e five right to
attack the knight now if Knight moves or
takes now the Queen could get exchange
these pawns are monster see if ninety
five mate right all right so ii five
should be one move to think about right
okay what else
what is another candidate move
the problem is some playing I mean after
a five the problem is if you play
something like 98 take take your cafe
take take and you're still stuck if five
is six is coming up you could try to
take or even here you could try to play
East six first or D six first and then
go four rakat fate like ecigs where do
you put your Bishop it's like yeah so
yeah the position is not really if you
if you have to play something like
ninety eight you're lost but before
diving too deep into e5 let's think
about other candidate news for white
all right hint think about takes first
okay that's I yeah that's something that
you could consider doesn't really help
your position and you have a pretty good
Center so what else
that should be one of your candidate
moves - and the other one is not very
easy to see so I'm just gonna say it d6
could also be one of your candidate
tools that's what mainly because it just
adds pressure simply and now it's asking
okay what do you want to do if it was
white to move again White's would go for
the move e5 whoops all right so let's
think about the first note we talked
about if I first so far we haven't found
anything for black like you touch the
knight you lose pretty much right so
don't touch the knight think about
intermediate moves you're attacking my
knight and I'm gonna attack something
bigger
yeah perfect that is actually pretty
strong move see the problem is if the
Queen goes away you just take the pawn
rook F ace doesn't really work anymore
you're not gonna get mated the Queen
goes away still take the de pon
yeah good enough because if now the
Queen's get exchanged it's one group can
one point to these two pieces and even
though why it might seem a little bit to
act more active white actually doesn't
have any advantage and it would be black
who would try to push for more like give
black to three moves to bring out the
King activate the bishop defend this
pawn and black would be very strong two
pieces are usually stronger than it
reckon upon all right so that's what is
going on with a five now
after understanding ye five is not good
because of h6 and losing d5 pawn that is
why you would think about a move such as
d6 so you would see e5 first and when
you CH six and then you see the line
with Knight takes d5 you would realize
that all right so my defy is hanging so
let's play d6 first keep the pawn their
add more pressure and get gamer space
all those fun stuff and now you actually
want to play e5 because now if let's say
it would if it were white to move again
white could do if by which if h6 Queen
goes away if you point 95 now this
position is actually pretty risky just
because I could simply try an attack
here or I could try and push for East
six like rook f7 where do you place your
bishop if you move the bishop I just
played d7 trying to make clean yeah
so that's why these six is the move to
think about now this is also pretty hard
so I'm gonna give you just a little bit
of time to absorb the position
but the problem the tiny problem with
these six is that now what black
wouldn't want to exchange the Queen's
off right so black should move the Queen
somewhere else that should be the first
thing that comes across your mind after
understanding the threat of a five I'm
going to an endgame and knowing that
that's losing for black you could start
thinking about all right so where do you
want the Queen to go now ideally you
would want to try and centralize your
queen how would you do that
something like Queen g8 and it looks
pretty unorthodox but it's actually a
very strong move because now if e5 we
could do Queen d5 and now this Queen is
pinning this pawn and pinning the rook
and it's it's just it's a magical Queen
because if you if wise would play
something like queen of four you could
simply move your night away see this
queen of eight wouldn't work anymore
because the rook is pinned right and you
can't take it back it's paint
so let's say you would play something
like Queen
efore and if the Queen's were exchanged
off just King g8 you'd protect the week
square you are attacking this guy and no
way to protect it so life gets pretty
easier as black and another thing to
consider is this h3 because after h3
what would you do you can't like you
can't take this night because of Queen
takes and then checkmate
so what else would you do after a ch3
keep thinking about how in pretty much
all over the game when a piece was
attacked black came up it's some
intermediate move to attack the bigger
guy yeah it's kind of crazy right but
it's what the position needs simply
because you can't take the pawn but you
really want to get rid of this pawn so
in order to do that g5 take take and I
would assume that they would go for
check check check and call it a day
which would be a smart decision because
well then the rook is hanging so least
of all so we looked at the lines 'if
i've and we realize because of h6 it
doesn't work we looked at the line d6
and then we saw this tricky queen comes
to g8 and then jumps to d5 and
centralizes and all those crazy stuff
now
after thinking about that you realize
that as white this 5d6 idea wouldn't
work so you start thinking about rook
takes up 6g takes f6 the other rook
takes f6 now you still have a pretty
good center like if you had two moves
this pawn would come here it's such a
monster now as black the other problem
is as white would one you would want to
play like Queenie five and start going
for the jugular
now as black as soon as you realize this
is this is what's happening you should
stop it how
it would really help if every move that
your opponent does when it's your move
you think all right what does white one
what does remind what does my opponent
what if it was his move again what would
you do
yep
white wants to play queenie 5 so stop it
yep that's one of give me another one
too oh no no don't
it's okay we like our Bishop so Queenie
eight is one move but Queen east seven
is the more stable move I want to say
because it's your rook is also coming in
the game so after Queenie seven Queenie
fat doesn't work anymore
how would you come up with a new planet
as white what would be that new plan
uh-huh
now your idea is to jump the rope in
France yeah okay so whoops pretty much
your idea is that you don't like this
Queen here because you want to place
your Queen here and you want this Queen
to move that's the gist of it
right okay so yeah that's pretty good
queen of for not a black understands
that this roof f7 is coming up so it's a
good idea to take that away how the
other way to think about it does this
Queenie five here would be very annoying
it's your king so your king could
possibly yep yeah you're simply
protecting of seven square and if this
Queen e5 happens it doesn't serve as
horrifying purpose all right so after
King g8 White's plans are all kind of
ruined white could play Queen g5 but
Queen g7 and I mean something like 25 it
doesn't make much sense anymore you just
bring in your rook you look after it
should be good enough anyways so you
still would want this Queen to move away
so II five sorry
d6 now the Queen can't really go back
because of check on g5 and those are
pretty scary so Queen g7 protecting your
king now mmm white realizes that's like
these this rook is good here the queen
is good here and let's try to keep
pushing pawns right and also some ideas
with checks probably so
if it was why to move again white wants
to play east six so your job as black is
to stop that
simple moves develop
I think when g4 even if take take six
that's still pretty scary all at queen
g4 may be simply Queen goes maybe take
take e six is this is really scary I I I
mean I don't think it's like losing
scary but you would have to be very
precise scary yeah that's actually the
way to go you're protecting this is
square for the moment so e six ain't
gonna happen
and if white tries to do some
interesting stuff like check you just
move the King away c6 still doesn't work
because the f6 rook is hanging now if
for example white gets to do the rupee
up seven that's been waiting for what
can you do now what's different
think about what's week in whites
position now
so you could think about this move what
do you what do you think what were you
afraid of thinking about this move rook
d7
okay
and now well black can has a perpetual
in considering black was under pressure
for most of the middlegame I think it's
a pretty good result yeah I mean if King
G for there should also be the strop
coming up so just King history and shake
hands yeah I mean not every crazy game
has to end in a in a win or loss so it's
it's now well I mean this this is black
clean decisive because blacks position
is under pressure what else can black -
maybe if here Y tries to do something
like T for I still don't think it's
worth that pressure but maybe this is
something that white could try to think
about it does now raakhi up 7
but even if even if it whoops even if it
was white to move and rookie up 7 still
queen g for everything is defended
I mean it still keeps the game in the
middle game but I dispatch it becomes
pretty strong coming up with some ideas
yeah I I kinda agree with the the way
both white and black went about it for
the last few moves because they both
found the best moves pretty much all
throughout the game so there is nothing
with the the the result of draw when
Hugh and your opponents all play the
best moves it's like I mean you deserve
it your opponent deserves it that's the
way I think about it if you if you can
find all the best moves and you can I
can find all the best moves well
but yeah this was a very interesting
game I I thought this was pretty cool it
was also a nice throwback yeah exactly
yeah well this is all I had for this
week's my choice and hope you enjoyed it
it was I think it was pretty cool and
thank you see you next time
[Music]
you